welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica kman filling in for Eric Voss
while he's out on paternity leave and
this is a breakdown of the trailer for
Godzilla X Kong the new Empire the 2024
followup to 2021s Godzilla vers Kong
2019s Godzilla king of the monsters
2017's Kong Skull Island and 2014's
Godzilla do you remember there's so many
movies there's so many of them this film
is coming out April 12th 2024 and this
trailer is freaking amazing so let's
break it down for the details that you
might have missed from the beginning the
trailer introduces Warner Brothers and
legendary logos to an ominous ethereal
singing choir fire the sounds like ream
a famous piece composed in the 1960s and
used in Stanley Kubrick's 2001 A Space
Odyssey it was also used in the 2014
Godzilla by Gareth Edwards to help sell
the Eerie otherworldly nature of
Godzilla just as kurick used it to cue
the black monolith like Godzilla
towering over the puny humans the black
monolith is a strange thing that is way
out of place with the primates in
pre-recorded history also observe the
pink and blue fog which appears to be a
predominant color Motif for the movie
The Mix of pink and blue which is not
only unusual for Kaiju movies but is
being associated with the new Kaiju
villain that will oppose both Godzilla
and K we see a seismic reader this
monitors large levels of movement in the
ground like earthquakes and volcanoes
but seeing as this is a Godzilla and
Kong movie it means a Titan is probably
coming it might be coming through this
section off Portion by what I assume is
Monarch we left Godzilla vers Kong
knowing there's a new Outpost within
Hollow Earth monitoring Kong we also
know from the movies in the series
there's a bit of Monarch Outpost
stations monitoring and standing by so
this might be one of the many post
around the world just setting up a
perimeter to another entrance to hollow
work we then get this beautiful shot of
the sun setting over the pyramids and
you know damn well a monster's about to
mess it all up there's a Rapture in the
sand the poor camels don't even know
what to think and the bricks surrounding
the pyramid are engulfed into the dirt
we get a good view of the seismic reader
and it's now freaking out just like
those camels then we get the shot a new
hole to Hollow Earth with the same blue
lighting flickers in the sand and out
comes Optimus primal nah but it kind of
looks like Optimus primal in like the
hand of Bumblebee's suit later it's
revealed this could be Kong and his like
Thanos Gauntlet but Jokes Aside could
Monarch have given Kong a new suit of
armor possibly this could be be a piece
of armor for him to protect himself the
overlapping audio says what else were we
wrong about girl everything ew mentioned
Godzilla and Kong will see a killer
Kaiju face off against a colossal
undiscovered threat that could very well
spell the end of days for both man and
monster alike what have we been
preparing for there have been rumors and
fake leaks and real leaks that we can
maybe expect to see shimu in this movie
and this scene could actually be Kong
fighting shimu who's emerging from the
sand and we're seeing the blue light
from their crystals a remixed version of
Jim Reeves Welcome to My World the song
was first written WR by Ray Winkler and
John Hathcock while written as a love
song the song is being used here for a
more dramatic effect of reintroducing
audience to Hollow Earth dimension of
Titans ruled by King Kong we also see
King Kong here with those flying
monsters we've seen in Godzilla vers
Kong before and you can see a tiny Kong
gorilla running in the distance but he's
being chased by something I can't really
make out it might be the death Jackal
that we see later Here Comes Kong
quickly landing and running back into
the gorilla Sprint last we saw of him
his fur was a little mangled and just to
be expected after you know battling
Godzilla so just to note yeah he's
cleaned up rather down with that old
man's beard and it's been a minute then
we see this machine flying in which I
don't think we've actually seen before
this could be an upgraded version of the
heave ship from Godzilla versus Kong
which was closer in resemblance with the
Super X and the Super X2 from earlier
movies all this to say we're time
jumping a little and like all previous
movies the technology is advancing with
the time then we see the doors opening
to a jungle and on the other side is EA
Andrews played by Rebecca Hall who we
saw in the last movie behind her is Dan
Stevens who is playing a new character
allegedly named Trapper but according to
IMDb it's Steven Ronda who could be
related to John Goodman's character Bill
Ronda in the apple plus series Monarch
Legacy of Monsters the series really
dives into Bill's history and we learn
about his past with his wife helping him
find evidence of these Titans before a
lot of other people did then we see a
Dusty old Kong settled up with his ax
and in front of him we see a shadow of
another monster the scene is probably
here to show us the scar king size he's
the movie's main villain and by the
trailer he looks to be a rival of Kong
for sometime the shadow shrinks down and
turns into this baby gorilla who looks
to be related to the scar King he's he's
so cute I feel really bad I just love
little babies I really like this scene
because it implies two partial things
one Kong could be afraid of this baby
turning into what the scar King is going
to be in the future or two this baby is
also trying to get away from the scar
King and Kong is very scared of this
battle that should play out soon between
him and the evil scar King so much can
be made from this scene and I'm excited
to just see them all fight but could it
be the son of Kong it could be a big
part of the holidays is food but that
doesn't mean every single night needs to
be a 20 course Masterpiece for the
nights when you don't really want to
cook you still want your food it tastes
like you did There's factor with Factor
you can choose from over 35 Chef crafted
meals every week that support a healthy
lifestyle and meet your meal preferences
calor smart vegan and veggie Protein
Plus and more wholesome options Factor's
fresh never frozen meals are ready in
Just 2 minutes so all you have to do is
heat and enjoy this month I got a factor
box and I had like a sundried tomato
cream chicken that tasted so freaking
good he what the hell is he doing I
don't know is he
dancing you can save the shopping
chopping cooking and cleaning for when
you've got family in town without
sacrificing nutrition or taste it's a
holiday Miracle you can also level up
with Gourmet plus options and treat
yourself to upscale meals with premium
ingredients like broccolini leaks
truffle butter and asparagus so head to
factor 75.com or click the link below
and use the code rockstars 50 to get 50%
off your first Factor box once again
that's factor 75.com or click the link
below and use the code rockstars 5050 to
get 50% off your first Factor box today
in 1933 shortly after the release of the
original film King Kong RKO radio
pictures FasTrack to production a direct
sequel of son of Kong in which King Kong
has a son who's only 12 feet tall and
had more affectionate personality the
movie's writer Ruth Rose said in an
interview about the movie slightly more
comedic change in tone if you can't make
it bigger make it funnier but this baby
looks
sad then Trapper says what is that and
we see a giant red handprint on the edge
of a wall which could be another call
out to how big scar King is and
resembles all the movie posters we've
been been seen lately Kong jumps down
into this Cave of crystals and monkey
skulls and the narration says who could
have done this personally I think it's
the big old orange one we've alluded to
this entire trailer then we're taken to
this incredible scene that resembles the
underground ruins that Kong was in and
Godzilla versus Kong like the temple
that he was in so this might be a place
where they worship a different true king
the scar King then we see an array of
death jackals chasing Kong and this is
the scene I think that could be the
scene that we saw earlier at the
beginning of the trailer we see a large
group of people likely indigenous to a
hollow Earth a staple Trope and all of
the King Kong and Godzilla movies are
isolated tribes of people sometimes
alien races who worship Kong and
Godzilla like gods they may also be ewi
a tribe of people from the monsterverse
franchise in the 2021 film Godzilla vers
Kong the character giia played by Kaylee
hoddle was an orphan from the tribe who
was taken by EA Andrews Rebecca Hall's
character however most of the ewee were
wiped out so the tribe here could be
survivors of a new tribe we've yet to
meet it looks like the scene also from
Godzilla and megalon you know the
worship ones we cut to a scene from
Bernie from the last movie played by
Brian Tyree Henry and Trapper who was
wearing the same clothes from previously
in the trailer so Bernie must have been
invited on this trip to Hollow Earth
behind them are men holding Spears so I
think these two men are being taken in
for questioning this looks like a giant
spine but it could be a staircase
leading out of Hollow Earth or something
more Divine we see it later in the
trailer this could be Gia also want to
know it looks like she's fading away
like around her hands whatever power or
light the stairs are emitting is like
taking away something from her this must
be in Brazil I only note that because of
the Brazilian flag at the top of the
screen a giant claw shoots down almost
impaling This Woman This Could Be Sila
by the SP appendage it could be that
Titan Godzilla thaws out of the ice and
is now empowered by a strange pink
energy our big baby hibernating in their
ice game the colors are pinkish purple
with blue tones like the ones from the
concave of the skulls we saw earlier
also like the colors of the staircase
it's all just coming back full circle
it's been revealed online that this is a
step in Godzilla's Evolution he draws
his energy from Hollow Earth this
radiation will give him seemingly new
powers and make him just very strong
he's also a big fan of Barbie just like
me then the big baby wakes up and
honestly he kind of ate I'm sorry sorry
I'm kind of in love with this neon pink
I mean like period purr but my favorite
part of the trailer is the scratching of
the seismic reader in the silhouette of
Scar King on The Lonesome freaking
Throne like this is like sua and ji-
Jitsu kaisen clearly this means he's
coming out of Hollow Earth and into the
real world or just something as big as
him is coming when scari jumps down it
terrifies the other and it's kind of
clear he's the one to be feared
especially with this transition to the
beach with him horrifyingly standing
over the people of Brazil we see
Godzilla readying his new Atomic breath
and the sound waves reverberating off
every Spike I love this scene we saw him
and Godzilla versus Kong use this so
this one might be just stronger than
that one then Kong Bellows and Godzilla
blows the atomic breath and boy I can't
wait abruptly Godzilla jumps out of the
ground and Kong falls from the ceiling
with the new Gauntlet Godzilla really
runs like me for real and I it's a read
it's read and a half the winning trailer
shot with both Godzilla and Kong teaming
up against the new threat confirms that
Kong gets a cool mechanical glove
probably to boost his strength or to
maybe heal a wound courtesy of possibly
Monarch that's it for my breakdown on
Godzilla X Kong very excited to see my
baby fight again follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at Lulu Clemens follow new
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching see you
[Music]
[Applause]
later